it is time now for CBS deals and this
morning we have products that might find
or might find make well they're going to
make your day brighter and a bit easier
how about we say that we will have them
at all exclusive low prices too so to
start shopping now scan that QR code on
your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com we've got Jessica teicher
Deputy editor for the Good Housekeeping
Institute she joins us here with more
and good morning good morning Michelle
yes all of these products have been
tested by our lab experts at the Good
Housekeeping Institute I love that
cannot wait to show you and have
everyone get started shopping on
cbsdeals.com we were just talking about
this today in the makeup room yes yes
tell me and describe yes okay so Beauty
set this is the universal sea skin
perfector plus SPF you already know how
much I love the serum from this brand
and now they've added in SPF so it's
skin protection and skin care benefits
and one easy step and you can see how
easy that rubs in wow and it lasts yes
really emollient yeah you really only
need a little bit you rub it in and you
get all of the benefits from that
vitamin C so 20 vitamin C is going to
brighten your skin fade
hyperpigmentation and discoloration
improve your skin texture really fast
over four weeks oh I love it and it's
SPF 50 and it's mineral so it's not a
chemical sunscreen either if that's your
thing alrighty yep what next do we have
so the price on this one today is 50 off
you can get it for 42.50 but all of
these products are available on
cbsdeals.com so whatever you need from
beauty sat today is the day 42.50 so we
have rugs here too yes okay so washable
rugs you can just toss this right into
your original washer and standard washer
and dryer yeah it's almost as hard back
as yes as we normally are used to
exactly this is my magic carpet and it
has this nice non-slip pad on the back
or backing on the back and there is no
rug pads you don't have to fuss with
with that you just put it down so easy
perfect if you have kids pets if you're
prone to stains and Spills like I am
it's just so convenient doesn't get
better very flexible how much today this
is up to 36 off with rugs starting at 55
and then also consider how much you're
saving on rug cleaners or getting a
carpet cleaner into your house it just
pays for itself really okay now what is
this okay if you have a dog at home like
I do you know the struggle with fur and
then lint as well this is uproot clean
and today this is a bundle of three and
it removes lint and fabric or it removes
lint and fur from pretty much any fabric
really yes so this is the mini and you
can see here just how easy it is I'll
see that I'll lift up I know okay so
this is the mini you put in your purse
keep it in your car do this to your
clothes on the go this is the pro which
is the original good for your everyday
task and then the max is twice the size
of the pro you can use it in your car
anywhere you have a larger area that you
want to clean but this would be for a
sweater too just to get the lint off of
uh it's awesome I use it on my couch
last night it was pilling a little bit
and it even got those pills off God how
much today this is 33 off you get it for
thirty dollars the entire bundle
and there's no refill so no rolls and no
waste which we love yeah we do it sucks
yes compression socks okay I recently
took my first 11 hour flight it's a
little crazy but these changed the game
for me compression socks are so
essential because they increase your
circulation and your leg energy and they
reduce swelling in your legs and your
feet and your ankles so perfect if
you're traveling or pregnant postpartum
you really want to have these on hand
these were designed by a physician too
so you know that they're really great
and they have a nice if you feel here
like they're a little bit padded but
they're not too much really comfortable
they don't slip down I'm obsessed how
much these are 20 off today you can get
them for 28 great deal for compression
socks which can get really expensive yes
they can look how cute they are
Jessica thank you so much and of course
we partner with all of these companies
to get these deals so to buy anything
you saw today scan that QR code on your
screen or head on over to cbsdeals.com